اللافته في العمليه التركيه الاستهداف
المركز لعين العرب كوباني المدينه ذات
الرمزيه الكبيره بالنسبه لقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه استهداف كوباني المركز ب 14
غار جاء بسبب ان قرار اعتداء اسطنبول
الاسبوع الماضي اتخذ في المدينه بحسب ما
افادت التحقيقات التركيه كوباني كانت اول
من تصدت لتنظيم داعش وخاضت وحدات حمايه
الشعب الكرديه فيها معركه ضده عام 2014
للدفاع عن المدينه وتلقت خلالها للمره
الاولى دعاما عسكريا مباشره
كتب المتحدث باسم الوحدات الكرديه نوري
محمد في تغريد ان مدينه كوباني البطله
اوقفت بما داعش وحامه الانسانيه وعلى
المجتمع الدولي ان يدعمها اليوم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
احد سكان عين العرب تحدث عن حالتي هلا عن
وخوفا بين السكان خصوصا على اطفالهم الذين
يبكون طوال الوقت نتيجه اصوات الانفجارات
القويه بدوره ندى القائد العام لقصد مظلوم
عبدي بالقصف التركي ووصفه بالعدوان الهمجي
اقل في تغريده ان القصف على مناطقنا
الامنه يهدد المنطقه برمتها وليس لصالح اي
طرف عبده اضاف انا قصد تبذل جهدا كي لا
تحدث فاجعه كبرى ولكن ان صارت الحرب
سيتاثر الجميع بنتائجها مهددا كما ذكرنا
بالرد على تركيا بالوقت والمكان المناسب
السيف ليست العمليه التركيه الاولى في
سوريا منذ العام 2016 سنه انقره ثلاثه
عمليات عسكريه استهدفت بشكل اسيا
المقاتلين الاكراد تمكنت انقره خلال هذه
التعاون مع فصائل سوريا مواليه بالسيطره
على مناطق واسعه تركيا هددت مرارا بشنه
هجوم جديد ضد المقاتلين الاكراد في سوريا
في وقت سابقا من العام الحالي الا ان
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان لم يحصل
وفق محللين على ضوء اخضر من ايران وروسيا
اللاتيني تمتلكان نفوذا واسعا في سوريا
للقيام بذلك لكن يا طاهر يبدو ان الضوء
اخضر اليوم